all right see
where are you from originally where'd
you grow up um I'm from New Jersey uh
originally
but I've been out in California now
since 2017 2018.
tell me about your family
um so I grew up in like a pretty strict
Italian Catholic home
um my parents have been together since
they were 16 which is super weird and
um like they've never been with anybody
else
um they're still together I have a
younger sister
um he's about four years younger than me
yeah it was like pretty easy growing up
like we looked like that picture-perfect
family so like for me to have gone down
the path I went down was like I don't
know I don't know if I was like
embarrassed of where I came from or like
just couldn't make sense of it in my
head you're embarrassed because it was
so privileged yeah like I you know
especially coming into like the rooms or
like even being on the streets or like
wherever I've been at at different
points in my life
um and on this journey it's like I hear
these horror stories and it's like I
always felt like maybe I didn't have a
reason
uh to use I think there should be some
trauma that you went through or
something like that yeah I mean there
and there definitely is I think I just
like
um like I'll I'll never know what it's
like to have to go between two parents
homes or
um like I always knew where my parents
were I never had to worry where a meal
was coming from or like if there was
running water I always had shoes on my
feet you know like things that are like
total questions now every day you know
so why do you think you're down here
um I mean like I kind of started using
drugs a lot later than most people I
didn't get into like hard drugs until
after high school
uh when I was 18 I got pregnant with
twins and when I was like eight and a
half months pregnant
um
the father of them beat the [__] out of
me and I gave birth to both of them and
they died
oh wow I'm sorry yeah so like that's
kind of
what kicked off me using it's like
I didn't do pills and into you know
drinking I just
I went straight to heroin
you know the [__] up part is like
for years I just used it as an excuse
you know poor me poor me you don't know
what I've been through you know
but yeah I've like pretty much ran my
life into the ground
and then I finally felt like I got out
of it like I got off the streets maybe
like almost three years ago you got
clean huh you got clean yeah I got clean
uh August 2020.
and then my fiance at the time died 45
days into my sobriety from heroin
and um I stayed sober up until about
last year and I got diagnosed with
cancer and was in another hospital and
I thought I had it like I'm like okay
I'm never gonna do drugs again and
immediately they gave me opiates in the
hospital and I was like oh that's it I
was in a different hospital the next day
like asking for like morphine again so
it was like really gradual this time
because like I had my own place and I
had a job in a car and I built up this
life so it took a little bit longer for
this stuff to physically kind of start
going away
a couple months ago like I came back
down here I'd moved to San Francisco so
so you had cancer or you did not no I
had cancer yeah I went through when I
was up in San Francisco I was going
through like radiation like targeted
radiation monthly and then um what kind
of cancer ovarian so I have one ovary
um
the hope is I can have kids again one
day I think that's like also super
triggering for me
um
how old are you 25 I'll be 26 in October
so that's the other thing is like I have
health insurance and I could literally
walk away from this at any point and I
think that's like [__] with my head as
it's like
like my parents like because I put time
together like there are people who are
like oh come get sober I have people
calling me or whatever like my car
someone slashed all four of my tires the
other day someone stole my keys like
it's just
like I've had every opportunity to leave
and I just like I'm constantly stuck
obsessing about like it's not even
heroin anymore now it's like I started
smoking crack and like that's by far the
worst I've never been addicted to
something like I could be having a great
day everything's fine money in my pocket
like healthy I've been sober for a month
and all of a sudden it's like the the
thoughts just start and it's like I
don't care
you know so it's like what are the
thoughts just like how like like it's a
crack all day like I want to go for a
crack I wanted this I want that like
I don't know I don't know what it is
it's like I've um like with Heroin
you're physically addicted like that
makes sense to me like I wake up and I'm
sick I have to use you know and it's
like oh I don't want to go detail
because I want to go through the pain
but like with it's something like a
crack cocaine it's like there's no
physical withdrawal I wake up the next
day and it's like maybe like I'm tired
or I'm irritable or whatever you take a
shower to eat you're fine but it's like
the mental obsession
I've never had that before so it's like
I don't know I don't ever remember it
being so difficult for me to get sober
but maybe I was like ready before I mean
I thought I was ready even now it's like
I'll go to rehab I'll leave
I'll like make a phone call go stay with
a friend for a couple days try to sober
up and then I'll leave and come right
back down and it's like
I don't know like someone said to me
today they're like see like you're not
ready like just stop fighting it you're
not running like
so I finally just got honest with
everyone like listen I'm not ready to
get sober like this is where I'm at
right now and it's like not ideal I'm
not it's like I'm running around having
the time of my [__] life
currently you're using crack crack and
um Fentanyl and Fentanyl too yeah
yeah where do you stay your new car uh
no I'm not staying in my car because I'm
too afraid I had to like kind of hide my
car it took me like three weeks to get
my car fixed get new keys and a new
battery in it and then somebody was mad
at someone I was hanging out with and
slashed all four of my tires so it's
currently like sitting somewhere on all
Flats my dad doesn't even know when the
car's in his name so
that'd be great but um no I'm staying in
like I'll just like hop around from like
10 to 10 or like just like ride my bike
around all night or I don't know
stay in like Apartments abandoned houses
what do you do for money
um
I guess it depends like sometimes I can
like man I'll like lie to my parents
like I'm going to rehab or
um I don't know like sell clothes sell
shoes
um I'm in a relationship which is like
oh cool like you have a boyfriend on
Skid Row but it's like great because I
don't have to sleep with anybody for
money which is like typically something
that would have been like really like a
big thing in the past but it's like I
don't know I just figured out there's
always there's something like whether
it's like my taxes that come in or um
I'm getting unemployment now hopefully
so like I'll I'll make it work to the
best of my ability and like robbed
people I've learned some [__] too so if
you had your life to live over again
would you have done anything differently
no
no I wouldn't I mean I'm not I don't
love where I'm at now but like
even when I was sober like before I
ended up down here like even on my way
coming down to go to rehab like I'd stop
here and like I just moved everything
out of my apartment in San Francisco
it's like I had a bunch of blankets and
pillows in my car and clothes and that's
like I'll get out of my car and I'll
like be like oh hey what's your name
like you want some water you want a
blanket like I asked people the same
couple questions like what's your name
like what's your situation like why are
you down here and like what are you
passionate about because like I remember
last time when I was homeless out here
like it's weird because like you're
invisible to like this like certain
class of people it's like oh they're
grabbing their purse they're grabbing
their kids they don't want to be near
you but then it's like you're also like
super exposed like everyone like you
know like there's nowhere to really hide
you don't have anywhere to go
so
um you know like uh the family I come
from like my like my mom and my sister
are really like kind of stuck up and um
maybe like a little bit fearful so they
don't know
um
but I don't know like I
I don't know I just know what it feels
like like we're still humans you know
like we're no different than anyone else
we just have a disease you know you
don't tell us about what cancer like oh
no like you know
uh you know you don't like bully someone
with cancer because they have to take
chemo you know like unfortunately like
when you're an addict you have like this
disease like in your brain and it tells
you you don't have a problem and it
tells you it's like it's like okay cool
if I do this shot of heroin I'm gonna
die and it's like okay cool I want to go
do that like that's not it's not right
like my brain is not right like it's
I can't explain it is there anybody else
in your family who struggles like this
well it's funny because like my whole
life I didn't think there was but um I
found out a lot later on my mom's
biological father died of her own
overdose so a lot of my mom's side of
the family has addiction problems um my
dad's side there's no one that we know
about and um
my mom not growing up she didn't really
drink much around me or my sister but
now as an adult
um
she's pretty bad and she I I can't
really obviously diagnose anyone as an
alcoholic or an addict but I would say
she's pretty
um unstable and out of control with her
drinking so
yeah
[Music]
do you have dreams of doing anything
else with your life
um I mean yeah I I when I got pregnant
with the twins I was in school I wanted
to go to the medical route I wanted to
be a doctor I wanted to be a surgeon
um
I I know I want to help people I was
like working in a non-profit business
before as like an executive assistant
which I didn't love but because it was
like really boring and slow and not
challenging for me but it did like get
me out of like chaos and it did keep me
on the schedule so
um I think at some point I just want to
own my own business I'm like really
creative
um probably something in the beauty
industry I do have my cosmetology
license
um but I just want to do something where
I'm somehow benefiting people or giving
back or
um like I want to be doing something for
other people I don't want to just to be
pointless you know is there a
self-destructive streak in you yeah yeah
I run off of emotions like I'm really
um
I got I know like there's like a lot of
therapy like in DBT schools they talk
about like the rational mind and the
emotional mind and their goal is to be
somewhere in the middle and I'm like way
far left in the emotional mind always
like I everyone's like oh like feelings
aren't facts and like my life like every
feeling is a fact and it's like it's
super impulsive like it's an immediate
knee-jerk reaction with no thought that
goes into it and of course I feel like
[__] afterwards but it's like I don't
care in the moment you know there's no
pause there for me
but what emotions are you going through
um it's like up and down because like
shame and guilt a lot of Shame and guilt
um a lot of fear
um like I'm in a place where like you
can't really be vulnerable like I cry a
lot it's like not really a thing you can
like do down here like people will see
that as weak and um I've already in the
month I've been back down here I've
gotten myself into a couple situations
so
you know it's like [__]
um
I don't know I try to like I try to be
strong I don't and people say that they
think I'm really strong and resilient I
don't feel that way on the inside but I
kind of just
try to stay positive and like get
through the next day and like hoping at
some point like I keep like crying so
whenever the [__] is up there and I'm
like hoping at some point like I wake up
and I have this like change of like
thought that's like okay like let's
let's do this like I'm running and I
don't know if it'll ever be a time that
I'm ready to get sober or not but
I'm just hoping that there's some sort
of willingness that pops back up
somewhere
how long you been in the streets
um
I mean I left home at 18 but um like I
said I had about two years almost three
years sober
and then like another period like you're
still like honestly like this is the
first time I ever had my own place for a
year but otherwise like pretty much over
the past five six years I've been like
in and out of sober living treatment you
know
um on the streets in motels kind of
never really settled down anywhere but
what do you what do you think the answer
would be to get you to straighten out I
don't know
I don't know like I wish I had the
answer like I
I don't know it's not common sense it's
not like no because you seem intelligent
enough to know right right and it's like
oh like okay cool I have insurance I can
go to some bougie ass like Treatment
Center in Malibu like a lot of people
can't do that but like that doesn't that
that's never worked like I don't want to
go sit in some Mansion everyone's like
oh but you could just go sit with a
private chef and Lie by the pool and
what the [__] is that gonna do for my
sobriety like it's not gonna do anything
it's gonna
you know but what do you think people
that are not in this life don't
understand about it
um I I think people just are I think
they're ignorant
um
I don't want to say that they don't
I think everyone has gone through their
own level of like trauma and like life
experience but I think people need to
stop and be a little bit more
compassionate and understanding like
it goes back to that rule they teach you
in [__] kindergarten like treat
others the way you want to be treated
like
we're all the same we're all just trying
to get through 24 hours a [__] day
and do the best we can maybe not
everyone maybe not everyone wants to try
to be a better person every day but I
think everyone at their like to their
own extent in their own capacity is like
doing the best they can
yeah
what's your biggest fear
that's the problem is I don't I I don't
I don't know what my biggest fear is
because I'm not afraid to die
um I think maybe my biggest fear is like
never being able to be a mom
um not being able to have kids and like
not accomplishing anything in life
like a lot of I've lost a lot of people
I've watched a lot of people die and
they've Left Behind like maybe a box of
clothes
you know
um
I at least want to be remembered for
something great you know do you think
there may be something like uh
borderline personality disorders yes
absolutely
that has been like um the word of the
year
um the problem is people can't really
diagnose you unless you have substantial
amount of time sober and I didn't get
diagnosed sober
so it's like
there's that up in the air is that what
you suspect though
I don't know
I think that I'm easily I'm easily
persuaded
and you're impulsive um
extremely extremely impulsive
definitely a fear of Abandonment I
definitely like cling to whoever I'm
like running with I always cling to like
my like whatever person's with me
so I think borderline would be an
accurate diagnosis but like when I was
sober I would tell you the complete
opposite so
I don't know yeah yeah what's your
greatest strength
probably like the fact that like I keep
getting knocked down over and over and
like the world has been pretty [__]
cruel but like you've hit some real big
setbacks yeah I mean I get up every time
um I don't stay down for too long and um
I nothing's gonna take away like how
much I love or like I'm passionate about
things
you know I try to say
as positive as possible
what's been your darkest point
your lowest point
um somewhere between
um
somewhere between my kids dying and like
it would be either that or like I had a
situation a couple weeks ago where I got
thrown in the back of someone's car and
like
I don't think I need to go into too much
detail about that but
um just like some low moments
um I've had to really take a really ugly
look at myself in the mirror yeah it's
hard for a female on the streets yeah oh
yeah
definitely different for women than men
I'll tell you that much
is it different is it is it more
difficult for
an attractive white female than a black
girl you think
I I don't know because I'm not I'm not
black but um
I think there's just different struggles
yeah
I mean all women are treated terribly
down here it's just it's it's as bad as
I can imagine the United States yeah
it's
it's pretty bad
but the drugs are here the drugs are
here that's the problem
that's the problem
you got like the shittiest like
predators in the world and then also
like people who are struggling and like
can't get sober
and there's that line of like we're or
all morals and ethics go out the window
on both ends
you know
a lot of snakes yeah
definitely seeing the world through a
totally different pair of lenses you
know
you think like all the stuff that they
like show in like those gangster movies
and like oh it was not real and then
you're like holy [__] is this really
like happening
the worst part is people just looking at
like no you're just way too high on
drugs
and then you're completely like
discredited so I don't even
waste my time trying to tell people
anymore what does your family think of
your situation
they want me to go get sober me and my
mom don't speak I don't think we'll ever
have a relationship to be honest
um it's always been like that since I
was young
uh my dad wants to get sober
is not the best at showing emotions or
like communicating with me but I know he
cares
so it does suck
it does suck because I know he's like
losing sleep like he's a fireman back
home so
he's riding the ambulance and
I know every time it picks up someone
from an overdose he's like worried and
he like thinks about me or every time
the phone rings I know he's worried it's
going to be a call about me have you
OD'd yeah
oh yeah
a couple times
a couple times the last time I overdosed
they hit me with Narcan a bunch of times
and I guess
um before the paramedics got there my
friend said like I looked at her and I
told her not to call an ambulance and um
I don't know if she tried to like inject
math or cocaine or something and like
wake me up but um I went to cardiac
arrest and the paramedics got there so
like I'm not even 30 and it looks like
I've had a [__] heart attack on my
EKG
it's like nothing is like like I think I
hit rock bottom and then there's like a
[__] trapdoor
it's like okay cool
it's just become the norm at this point
which is like really sad
because I was like
so far away I thought I would that and
that's the problem is I thought I was so
far away from this like I got really
cocky and like into ego when I was sober
like I forgot that like it's one wrong
move one bad day one wrong decision and
you're right back to where you started
it picks up right where I left off when
you relapse you relapse back at the spot
you dropped off you know you quit it oh
yeah you're at your lowest point right
away
you don't build up to it it seems yeah
from what I've heard
see what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um I think I need to be more honest with
myself and other people where I'm at
um
it's like I feel like I have to put on
this Persona that's like this front that
I'm okay
um
and I should have maybe reached out a
lot more when I was struggling in my
sobriety
um but I have to be honest with myself
first in order to be honest with
everybody else around me so
all right see thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck you're super young yet sir